Transcription: Jane _
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Bonjour.
Bonjour à tous !
Bonjour au président au fait,
président d’ESTACA qui est là,
qui me surveille !
Donc je vais essayer
d’être concis et un peu précis.
On m’a demandé de parler de la voix
sous toutes ses formes,
la voix dont on parle,
qui véhicule des émotions.
D’ailleurs, vous pouvez entendre la mienne
à France Info quand je parle de mobilité.
Et puis la voie qu’on prend dans la vie,
qui peut être différente,
qui peut être choisie ou imposée.
Et pour ça, je me suis permis
de prendre un fil conducteur
qui est ma vie, simplement,
les voies que j’ai prises.
Ça va d’ingénieur à moniteur d’équitation,
chef de village à musicien, etc.
Et puis, c’est surtout
des chemins de traverse
et c’est ce que je souhaite
à tout le monde,
c’est qu’on puisse
avoir le droit de changer d’avis.
Et pour ça, je me suis référé
à un monsieur,
il y a 500 ans, il a écrit ça.
Il a écrit pourquoi et il a dit :
« Parce que la science n’est pas la seule,
ou toute seule,
qui peut résoudre tous nos problèmes. »
Et qu’elle est capable
du meilleur comme du pire.
Je vous prends, par exemple, le nucléaire
qui nous fournit l’énergie
dont on a besoin
et qui peut être redoutable
en cas de conflit.
Et puis, je me suis aperçu,
en découvrant cette phrase,
quand j’étais élève à l’ESTACA,
qu’il était difficile de choisir sa voie
et qu’en même temps, je demandais
à la direction de l’époque
de rentrer dans le 21ᵉ siècle.
On était au 20ᵉ siècle !
Et donc pas de réponse.
Alors finalement, la meilleure solution
pour essayer de convaincre,
c’était de racheter l’école.
C’est ce qu’on a fait,
avec des copains de promo,
avec les parents d’élèves,
avec les industriels.
On est devenu propriétaires de l’école.
Situation un peu particulière
parce que nous recrutions finalement
les profs et on les notait.
Évidemment, ils recevaient de l’argent
et on en dépensait.
Donc, on a mis les choses dans l’ordre.
Et ce n’était pas plus facile
pour avoir le diplôme, pas du tout.
Je crois qu’en s’appropriant l’école,
on est tombés dans la cour des grands.
D’abord, on s’appelait l’ETACA.
Alors la première chose à faire,
c’était d’y rajouter un S.
C'est ce qu'on a fait.
S comme supérieur.
C’est-à-dire qu’on rentrait
dans la cour des grands,
y compris des écoles comme l’ENAC,
qui nous offrait, avec notre diplôme,
de rentrer directement
en formation de pilote de ligne.
C’est ce que j’ai fait.
Tout ça pour vous dire
qu’on a toujours le choix de sa voie.
Mais, en cas d’accident,
c’est pas tout à fait pareil.
Alors,
voilà, j’avais six ans
et j’étais confronté à un accident.
Pas le mien, celui de mon père,
qui, dans la résistance, est décédé.
Et, quand j’avais six mois,
on était fragilisé à cette époque,
on s’appelait “pupille de la nation”.
Ça veut dire, on était habillé,
par la nation reconnaissante,
d’une cape, d’un béret, de godillots,
et on était reconnaissable à 150 mètres,
ce qui était assez frustrant
parce que je voulais juste
être comme tout le monde.
Donc déstabilisé, fragilisé.
On en veut un tout petit peu
à la société et à son école.
Il y avait marqué
sur mon bulletin scolaire
“présence intermittente et encombrante”,
évidemment.
Donc pas beaucoup d’avenir
de ce point de vue-là.
Et l’école, finalement,
c’était la rue, les bandes,
les profs étaient les caïds du coin
de la cité voisine.
Et un jour,
je rencontre quelqu’un qui me dit :
« Écoute, j’ai trouvé
une école d’ingénieur
qui prend sans bac. »
J'avais pas le bac, évidemment.
« Eh bien vas-y,
je te paie la première année
et ensuite tu te débrouilles. »
Je l'ai fait.
Je suis resté.
Et j'ai appris et j'ai redécouvert
le goût d'apprendre.
Il y a quelqu’un qui disait :
« Pour changer la société,
il faut changer les hommes
pour changer les hommes,
il faut leur donner envie. »
Tout d'un coup, j'avais envie.
Et puis beaucoup plus tard,
j’ai remboursé un petit peu ma dette.
Pas forcément à la personne,
mais pour des jeunes.
Je leur fais construire encore aujourd’hui
et pas loin d’ici
un petit avion sur lequel ils volent,
pour des gamins qui savent
à peine lire et écrire.
Et donc je leur donne une chance.
La chance qu’on m’a donnée,
je l’ai restituée.
Ça a été formidable
parce que pour la petite anecdote,
lorsque l’avion est fini,
(c’est un kit d’ULM
qu’on voit derrière, là)
et qu’on fait le premier vol,
je fais le premier vol et je dis :
- Qui est d’accord pour voler avec moi ?
- Moi, moi…Tout le monde.
Je dis d’accord, mais on va regarder
un petit peu avant de partir,
On va faire ce qu'on appelle la checklist.
Alors je dis : « Tiens, il manque
un boulon là, on est morts. »
« Là, il manque de la colle,
on est morts. »
« Là, on a monté l’hélice à l’envers,
ça ne va pas le faire. »
« Mais on n’a qu’une vie,
on a des parachutes,
qui veut venir quand même ? »
Personne.
Je leur dis : « Dans ces cas-là,
on va faire ce qu’on appelle
dans l’industrie, là où vous serez,
un contrôle qualité. »
Et finalement en s’amusant,
on leur faisait prendre,
on leur fait prendre,
(j’en ai sorti quand même 700 gamins)
dans des métiers,
parce qu’autour de l’avion,
il y a la menuiserie, il y a la mécanique,
de l’électricité, etc.
Et ça a été un mouvement formidable
qui s’étend
à travers la France aujourd’hui,
à travers une association
dont je suis le président aujourd’hui,
qui s’appelle Aviation sans Frontières.
Bref, je reviens à cette époque.
J’étais devenu ingénieur comme mon père
et puis, pilote comme ses frères,
mes oncles.
Sauf que c’était la guerre
et ils ont été pilotes de chasse.
Alors pour la petite anecdote aussi,
Il y en a un, des jeunes,
il avait à peine 18 ans,
il s’est fait descendre,
donc il est mort prématurément.
Il avait choisi cette voie
qu’il savait dangereuse, pourtant.
Et puis l’autre, il est parti en Russie
pour se battre sur le front russe
pendant la guerre,
avec des pilotes russes,
et il a descendu un Messerschmitt.
Le pilote allemand s’est éjecté.
Il était sous son parachute.
Il a épargné ce pilote.
Et lui, à son tour, s'est fait descendre
par un autre avion allemand.
Il a sauté en parachute également
et le pilote qui avait vu la scène
l’a épargné aussi.
Eh bien après-guerre, évidemment,
j’ai pu rencontrer
les deux pilotes allemands
et mon oncle, réunis.
Ils m’ont lancé un message
qui est la réconciliation,
et c’est quelque chose
de beau à transmettre,
quelle que soit la voie qu’on prend,
il faut écouter les autres et puis,
envisager l’avenir.
Alors, j’étais devenu pilote de ligne.
Et quelles que soient les machines
sur lesquelles on est amené à piloter,
eh bien, on doit respecter des règles,
évidemment, on doit avoir
cette notion d’équipage.
“Équipage” c’est un mot qu’utilisait
Mermoz, pour ceux qui connaissent.
Ça a été le premier chef pilote
à Air France
et on doit avoir
ces qualités intellectuelles :
écouter, comprendre l’autre,
c’est la sécurité.
C’est comme ça que le transport aérien
est devenu le plus sûr du monde.
Donc j’avais, dans ma formation,
appris qu’il fallait faire ça
et apprendre des autres.
Et pour raconter une histoire,
j’étais en escale, jeune copilote,
je venais d’arriver,
j’étais sur Boeing et puis
au bord de la piscine à Dubaï,
je lisais un bulletin qui s'appelle
le bulletin de sécurité des vols.
Et il ramassait tous les mois
tous les incidents
et les accidents du monde entier
pour qu’on puisse apprendre
et se sortir de situations,
quelques fois, difficiles.
Mon instructeur, commandant de bord,
regarde et dit :
« Mais qu’est-ce que tu fais ?
Tu ne peux pas t’amuser ?
C’est pas comme ça
que tu deviendras un as de l’aviation. »
Le soir, on décolle pour Bombay.
Il met la puissance.
Il était aux commandes,
moi, j’étais à la radio.
J'annonce la vitesse.
182.
Il tire sur le manche et il me dit :
« C’est bloqué. »
Il ne peut pas décoller,
et on voyait le bout de piste arriver.
Je lui hurle « à moi les commandes ! »
Sans explication,
je pousse sur le manche.
Je recale ce qu’on appelle le “trim”;
c’est la gouverne de profondeur.
Je retire.
Et on a décollé,
à dix secondes près,
on était tous morts et je n’aurais pas été
là pour vous contraindre à m’écouter.
Donc l’expérience des autres,
c’est essentiel,
quelle que soit la voie qu’on choisit.
Et puis j’ai eu une deuxième anecdote,
beaucoup plus tard.
J’étais commandant de bord
et instructeur sur Airbus, cette fois-ci,
et j’ai été confronté à une situation
qu’on ne répète pas dans les simulateurs.
J’avais un passager...
qui voulait se suicider.
Il est rentré dans le cockpit
et m’a coupé mes quatre moteurs
et un avion sans moteur,
c’est pas une situation d’avenir.
On s'est bagarrés.
Ça a été assez compliqué.
J’ai dérouté, lancé un :
«Mayday, Mayday, Mayday »
et finalement on a pu
résoudre le problème.
Bon, il est mort dans le cockpit,
ce qui n’était pas du tout évident.
Et puis...
J’en appelle à la folie des hommes, quoi.
La folie des hommes,
je la cite comme étant
quelque chose de maîtrisable.
J’avais un instructeur,
quand j’ai été candidat astronaute, russe,
qui me disait : « Tu sais,
tu es déjà sur un vaisseau spatial. »
Je dis « Ah bon ? »
Et il me dit : « Oui, c’est la Terre. »
La Terre, c’est un vaisseau spatial
qui file à 105 000 km/h autour du Soleil
et nous en sommes responsables.
Nous en sommes responsables
parce qu’on va décider de son avenir.
Ne serait-ce que la biodiversité,
qui disparait par centaines,
tous les jours !
Et pourtant on en apprend beaucoup
avec la biodiversité.
On apprend le martin-pêcheur qui fonce
à 100 kilomètres heure dans l’eau.
On a la forme du TGV,
avec un oiseau
au bec bien calibré pour ça.
On a les winglets,
en bout d’aile, des aigles,
qui permettent 5% de consommation
en moins pour les avions.
Bref, la nature nous donne
des idées formidables
parce qu’elle a mis des millions d’années
à se mettre au point.
Et il me disait :
« Si on peut corriger et faire en sorte
qu’on protège la biodiversité,
on aura gagné quelque chose
et on aura gagné beaucoup d’années. »
Quand on a dit ça, on a dit qu’on
pouvait rajouter, à ce moment-là,
beaucoup à la voie qu’on avait choisie.
Moi, je souhaiterais
(mais j’en appelle
aux dirigeants de l’ESTACA aujourd’hui)
que la bionique, la bio respiration,
c’est pas une option.
Ça devrait être...
très incitatif.
Je dis pas “obligatoire”
on n’aime pas ça,
mais quelque chose qui donne le choix.
Bon alors, voilà.
Quand je parle de folie,
c’était ça, à bord.
Ça, c’est l’avion sur lequel j’étais
quand on a détourné ce passager.
Ça m’amène à la formule d’Einstein,
puisqu’on en parlait tout à l’heure.
On est dans une folie perpétuelle
qu’il faut maîtriser.
Cette folie,
je la rencontre aujourd’hui,
parce qu’il se trouve que je pars
en mission pour Aviation sans Frontières
avec des petits avions.
Et ces petits avions,
ça a été un peu bricolé
parce qu’on n’avait pas
beaucoup de moyens au départ.
Ça, c’est au Honduras,
qui était en pleine guerre.
J’ai évacué des passagers,
des populations civiles.
Et puis on s’est amélioré,
on est devenu une compagnie aérienne,
ce qu’on est aujourd’hui.
Avec des Cessna qui font douze places,
on se pose dans les villages.
Là, c’est Thomas Pesquet,
qui est notre parrain
et notre pilote bénévole.
Lors de ces missions,
on rencontre des gens extraordinaires.
Le premier que je vais vous citer,
c’est le professeur Mukwege.
Il est prix Nobel.
Il répare les femmes.
Il faut savoir qu’au nord du Congo,
au nord de la RDC,
à la frontière du Rwanda,
il y a des centaines de femmes
qui se font violer tous les jours.
Toutes les semaines,
tous les mois peut-être, mais beaucoup.
Et c'est insupportable.
Parmi d’autres malheurs
qui nous arrivent autour,
je veux dire, quand on voit
des enfants qui meurent de soin,
des femmes qui meurent de soin et de faim,
dans des situations
extrêmement dramatiques,
avec des millions de réfugiés
qui sont bloqués sur les frontières,
on met une gradation
de ce qui est important ou pas
dans la vie.
Ça permet de remettre, là aussi,
les choses en place.
Ce professeur Mukwege,
qui répare les femmes donc,
fait de la formation
et nous avons un petit avion
qu’on a pu lui confier
et on lui a offert
la voie dans laquelle il voulait aller,
c’est-à-dire,
être au service du plus grand nombre
et puis retrouver la dignité surtout.
La deuxième personne
est moins dans l’urgence.
C’est un autre prix Nobel
qui est lui du Bangladesh,
qui a inventé
le microcrédit,
la Grameen, il appelle ça.
C’est-à-dire, vous prêtez 10$
à un cireur de chaussures
pour qu’il achète son cirage
et qu’il vous rembourse
suivant ses besoins.
Comme ça, il a sorti
50 millions de personnes de la précarité
en Asie, en Afrique.
Et c’est formidable
parce que là aussi,
quelle que soit la voie
que vous allez prendre,
regardez un petit peu ailleurs.
Même à côté de nous,
aux frontières,
on voit des familles entières
qui se noient presque tous les jours
parce qu’elles fuient ces populations.
Elles fuient la violence,
les viols, les exactions, etc.
Et donc mon souhait ce serait que,
quelle que soit la voie
que vous choisissez,
vous vous demandiez :
« Qu’ai fait de bien
aujourd’hui pour les autres ? »
On a toujours quelque chose à faire,
du plus petit au plus grand.
Et ça, ça conforte dans le métier.
Je pense que les dirigeants d’entreprises
sont assez friands
de gens qui s’engagent pour la société.
Je vais vous présenter un troisième
personnage qui m’a beaucoup marqué
parce que j’étais
un de ses directeurs de campagne.
C’est ce monsieur-là.
Voilà, on a fait la campagne avec lui
et ce qu’il y avait d’intéressant,
c’est qu’il a pris, lui, l’humour,
comme arme de guerre, si j’ose dire,
pour convaincre les gens,
pour montrer aux politiques,
avec une glace,
ce qu’ils font de bien et de moins bien.
On a monté, du coup,
quelque chose d’utile
pour pouvoir ruisseler, on peut dire,
pour pouvoir donner l’exemple,
c’est les Restos du Cœur.
On croyait qu’il y en avait
pour quelques années.
Ben non, il y a toujours les besoins
et les besoins qui sont grandissants.
On a acheté un nouvel avion
avec 12 places au lieu de quatre
parce que les besoins étaient croissants.
Et là, on a multiplié
les points de livraison des Restos du Cœur
parce que là aussi,
c’est très handicapant pour la société.
Et puis je terminerai
par un autre monsieur.
J’ai commencé ce petit entretien
avec Rabelais
qui rappelait ce qu’était la science,
aujourd’hui et demain.
Et ce monsieur,
ce n’est pas il y a 500 ans,
c’est il y a 2500 ans !
Il a dit que finalement
il fallait s’en prendre qu’à soi-même
et qu’on a toujours le choix,
le choix de détruire
ou de construire, par exemple.
Et en vous regardant,
je suis assez optimiste.
Je vous remercie.
(applaudissements)